good
morning Millennials happy Tuesday happy
presale lunch day for the dirty jeans
tour final leg extravaganza djt also
it's the day after met Monday so I'm
feeling hungover even though I wasn't
like technically invited you know per se
totally I feel hungover from the for our
live stream that we watched him we're
doing Rancic was hungover she was
literally asleep like her elbows were on
the table like to do her mother she
turning there's right it was it was a
weird stream it was like none of them
wanted to be there it's like they were
all individually offended that they
weren't actually at the back gala
totally and that they have to comment on
the McHale and like each one was
competing with the other about how much
insider information they have yeah
really their information like either
came because like ryegrass he styled
some people or like they get pressed
emails which like I get to you know I
mean honestly I do think Bradley Gretzky
like in some universe that could have
been invited so I did think like it was
truly like weird for him to be there
also I'm Elaine vinyl to earth like
she's a judge on Project Runway she's
like the former editor of Teen Vogue
like she could have been there too so I
understand but like Zanna Roberts Rassi
like totally thought you should be there
and Zanna Roberts Rassi
looked nuts with a blue eyeshadow and
her blue dress she looked like the
Kardashians in Tokyo but did she look
camp
oh yes actually you know as I was
watching the livestream unfold I was
starting to understand a little bit more
but what I was really understanding was
that nobody was understanding and I was
I really I feel like at the end of the
day after seeing all the looks I have a
good sense of what they meant as camp to
me Campbell always be like you know was
almost whistles clipboards counselor's
Finch but met Callas understanding of
camp like I feel like I get it that
there's but I'm so funny it's like later
in the night when people were starting
to walk the red carpet on the e-news
livestream they would like zoom in on
people's shoes and stuff and you could
see on the floor the carpet was covered
in people's like feathers beans ruffles
like people were literally unraveling on
the carpet the carpet started out pink
but it ended up by the end of the night
being multicolored I mean that's pretty
cam variation of cam okay so we're gonna
talk about it a little bit we're gonna
get into the Nitty Gritty on the patreon
because we don't want to inundate this
whole episode with Met Gala coverage
because there's so much else going on
like presale which started at 10 o'clock
for all the Eastern Standard Time shows
which is Pittsburgh its daily it's
Toronto it's Richmond its Virginia Beach
its Charleston a bunch of others New
York is going on at noon because like
I'm feeling like making it special in 20
minutes that's the Central Time
since our so confused you work he's
going on sale at noon yeah well pre-sale
pre-sale okay it's still confused so
you're like Morgan Stewart trying to do
the nightly pop time okay let me tell
you like we're on ten thirty thousand
seven eight and 11 o'clock another you
know it's very confusing
okay so shows in some cities it's live
and some cities it's not if you want to
be eligible for free for presale all you
have to do is become a patreon member
it's $9 WWE trend calm forward tous
sailor so the shows that already went on
sale at 10:00 a.m. this morning we're
Pittsburgh Philly Lexington Charleston
Toronto Richmond and Virginia Beach so
those have been on sale for 40 minutes
I do hear that some of the shows are
flying off the shelves a catering job in
20 minutes which will be Central Time
at 10 p.m. 10 a.m. Minneapolis Austin
Chicago Milwaukee New Orleans are we
feeling each other yet yeah then at noon
in New York the beacon is going on sale
and I would just I will remind you I
will be like literally putting up a
picture of my vagina on Instagram like
just for attention you know right
because that's an important moment well
maybe tease your vagina on Instagram so
you can see the whole thing at the
beacon in the orange at ticketmaster.com
slash beacon yeah then at one o'clock my
time which is 10:00 a.m. Pacific time
the rest we got Los Angeles San Diego
Seattle Vancouver Portland Vegas San
Francisco that's it so I'm hopefully
trying to make that less confusing for
everyone but you don't have like when I
was on the phone with everyone like they
were talking about presale and the
managers and everyone they were like so
10 a.m. local time I'm like okay so all
the shots are going on sale today and
qua got it there are no local time I'm
like you know I'm in New York so it's
done yeah I just think the world
revolves around Eastern Time huh it does
sometimes when things are live like Game
of Thrones is on us because at rock west
coast which is so interesting so weird
but like it should revolve around
central or mountain time it's just so
weird and then ABC Family's always like
8/7 central you know you just really
because it's how kids which is really
helpful i just-i can't-- done attend and
they went so head over to
patreon.com/scishow morning toast get
your tickets to the girl with no job
show dirty jeans tour I'm so excited
me too I got it I think I'll go I'm
obviously going to begin but I think I
can use it as an opportunity to see a
little bit more become new great trip to
Asbury Park New Jersey maybe a trip to
New Orleans I've never been okay you
know I would love to take her advice on
this cuz I was thinking for the final
leg of like dropping the pajamas like
that'll stick like
was in slippers okay I could understand
that but then it opens up a whole can of
worms of what do I wear for this right
so I would have to have like an official
outfit like for for the shows which is
difficult as well yeah I mean
technically you should be wearing dirty
jeans right so there's always been this
like big hiccup like this huge like
controversy
I'm conflicting myself it's the heavy
gear store in the tour and I'm wearing
clean pajamas you know right like these
what I'm wearing now is actually like it
was the inspiration behind that read
like these are the jeans I have
literally not worthy not taking these
jeans off and I'm my period but it was
the ripped jeans oh yeah I don't rip 20
more you guys everyone like you can wear
black jeans every day and technically
you could say they're different every
day
yeah the same rips in the same places
you're wearing the same jeans every day
yeah and they're dirty jeans five days
in a row that's an interesting point I
think you should stick to this look to
the PJs that you do know get you know
it's between going well so far
despite the hypocrisy and like you don't
want to add a layer of like discomfort
on stage at least that's one thing that
you like I can breathe that you can rely
on it's like okay no matter how
treacherous this road gets like at least
I'll be comfortable in the real houses
of Atlanta reunion when Nene got there
super late she like just strolled in to
hair and makeup
in this red it was like exactly what I
wear on stage long-sleeve pajamas red
ball sequins and it was so cute and I
wanted to find it in black but it's
apparently like from her store I
couldn't find it I could go for use
doing the pajamas and different colors I
don't need sequins personally that adds
like another layer of jeans pajamas the
ball wins it's like you're adding a
third element
totally um but I could go for red PJ's
breads not really my color please just
switching it up based on the city was
Caesar bowling back then there you go
yeah so it's solved so you answered your
own question I should say people are so
funny like when I release the big poster
they're like people like get really
angry and this girl was like and I don't
really respond to anyone with I
literally had to respond to this one the
scar was like and you're not coming to
Louisiana oh my god what do we did to
you and I'm like girl look at the poster
Louisiana's right there right like I'm
not gonna respond to it for me like how
could you not to Boston like [ __ ] where
were you and I did two shows at the will
burn like please Atlanta I can't when
you hate southerners like girl I was
gonna let us shout shucking four tickets
left and right swipe out so I'm up so
respond temper but this girl was
literally like are there any cities that
you're not going to that you never went
to that really feel maligned okay like
there has been absurd there's like some
there's Wichita bit of outcry for Kansas
City okay it's just like that I think
that's such a small city like I it was
on the list I was just like that Boise
in Omaha I was just like I don't think
anyone will show up and like it'll be a
waste of money in time to just Trek
there if you went to Boise I would have
gotten with you I think um a lot of
places I want to see Boise and then you
tell me not to I here Boise's beautiful
this heart but if you are ever like
listen I need you in Boise you know I
would be there your problem is you're
like I said I needed you anywhere you
would be there of course the problem is
not only is you not say that you say
please don't come you know I really
don't really like when we're all
planning on like getting a tour bus and
going to Boston and then you were like I
don't want people I know it's just like
it's so much pressure and like even in
Huntington in Long Island like Ben came
and I was a nightmare before like
literally throwing things in the dresser
like I was truly Mariah Carey and it's
because the bed like he just makes me
nervous so Ben's like I'm gonna come to
the LA show and I'm like no and Ben
wants to come cuz it's gonna be like
celeb they'll you know right and like
it's too important of a show like
there's important people coming I'm like
sorry no he's like I'll sit outside I'm
like no he can buy a ticket and like sit
in the audience out telling you know he
can tell he's in Los Angeles
no he could figure out a way to get Los
Angeles without telling you and sneak
into I had this location on my phone
though and find my friends like he would
not be able to get past me I'm an ocean
I'm a true snoop I have that for anyone
and like sometimes I really need it I
just have to say like when I started
sharing it with people I'm like they're
gonna know where I am and then now I
have a bunch of people's locations and
I'd never look at it unless they're like
I'm five minutes away and I'm just like
to see how really close yeah and it has
been so helpful I have Olivia I have
Margo I have been I'd like a couple
friends you don't have me no I don't do
you want it I like to do fight like oh I
don't need it because you're always
standing right we've both went home from
the airport like I just wanted to see
where you were oh yeah faster but other
than that I don't eat it I guess I could
use it on my husband but you know what
we get each other our privacy like we
don't have each other's passwords for
stuff like I don't know if that's weird
or if it's horrible no I have Ben's
passwords I've been using them less and
less and I really love having Ben's
location because Ben is that guy who's
like oh come I'm here and then
outside like a hooker for an hour my
husband so it's nice to be like he says
I'm here and he's really six blocks away
and I will come down when your one block
away yeah that's true that's why it's
the most helpful in to a situation yet
where it's like okay now give me your
location I've asked her a few times but
it's never been necessary well I feel as
if maybe you would it would enhance your
relationship take it to the next level
you think so it probably would but like
it's kind of nice having like he doesn't
mind like I could be anywhere in the
world that's exciting but are you going
I could go to Los Angeles and even know
that's true you know that's an exciting
thing to think about
agreed you know marriage is it's a big
commitment that you're committed to
sometimes you just need your space
that's the thing about city you should
go to Los Angeles that's the thing about
being committed it requires a lot of
commitment yeah we heard that up on the
livestream they were just like talking
to nonsense every time they saw some it
was a new person this was that but it's
like they gave the camera zendaya she
said hey it was pretty well but it would
have been like anyone anyone Kris Jenner
yeah it's just like screaming she's like
oh and don't bother
I know a lot of campy vibes but you know
what I'll say really saw no bras not one
person on the Met Gala pink carpet was
wearing a bra and that's why I feel as
if I will never be invited right third
love was not present the love was not a
sponsor I just like it present on this
show here they are because they respect
the hell out of us and we respected the
hell out of them and they're fit finder
quiz all you have to do is answer a few
simple questions and you find your
perfect bra fit in 60 seconds over 12
million women have taken the quiz to
date it's actually really fun and takes
less than a minute to complete they have
a hundred percent fit guarantee every
cut someone has 60 days to wear it wash
it and put it to the test if you don't
love it return it and third-level wash
it and donate to it donate it to a woman
in need um I didn't know that I love
that they've the best comfort equality
hands down the most comfortable bra I've
ever worn like literally scoops and
separates that's like all I need from
about everyone has different needs
that's why the fit friend requests this
move there's nothing like it a scoop and
separate third love knows there's a
perfect bra for everyone so right now
they're offering our listeners 15% off
your first order
go 2/3 love.com slash morning toast now
to find your perfect fitting bra and get
15% off your first purchase
that's third love.com slash morning
toast for 15% off today exciting truly a
okay are you ready to talk to McHale are
you ready to get into I don't know the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast I don't know am i
okay Who am I just guess guys want to
touch my third love chest oh my god
twins Oh guys I just got like way too
excited I think I actually farted like
wow Jill who's shat in my pants oh my
god that was so funny okay before we get
into the stories that we're like a
little newsy about Met Gala I want to
just get your pulse I'm like best dress
and worse dress like some of your
favorites some of your least favorites
because I have I think I have mine when
I think of best dress I always like have
a hard time being like who I love the
most but like I mean I'm really am not
like her number one fan I don't know a
lot about her work but Janelle Monae was
my best dress like the blinking I was at
first it started to move in I'm like oh
no the eyes falling and then a piece
itself back up genius the hats the hair
hearts like that I mean I don't know
what campus but I have to think that
that's it so for me it's so weird like
the person that I love and like I just
like maybe she was a best dress but like
I just love her the most of course and
by the way she was up there with best
dress she was totally on theme for me
I'm she best dressed one person who was
in theme and the best dress for the
theme and then just like look beautiful
but what the [ __ ] was I thinking well
your first one is my first one best
dress for the theme is Kendall yes I
believe that and also go see the I know
there Kendall Kylie like I'm showing up
together them like looking like a bottle
of Fanta as Kristen outs so Kim that's
so camp no they were so camp they were
so beautiful
I felt like Kylie really felt like
herself it was like this theme was made
for her like this is what she wears
around her house and yeah features in
like she looks like just a purple dream
she got to wear her wigs and I'm so
happy for her but like Kendall just
looked all of that and then beautiful
yeah like Kylie's was like borderline
trashy with the Tenderloin but like I
but she if anyone could do it it's her
but she was herself and she looked she
looked incredible her body was tuned
action like she was wonderful like
Kendall was issue she encompassed the
theme and the moment and the Met Gala
and hell feathers like she really looked
fantastic she looks fantastic I loved
everything about her look including some
of her new facial features which you
know I can relate to because I just got
fresh Botox yesterday and I got fresh
lips yesterday and I'm so swollen like
usually I put on aquaphor and you know
you like rub it all around your lips I
can't even like
you know when you make them oh my god
hurts so so they're gonna go down a
little bit and you know what like I
thought I wanted huge lips and now that
I'm small and I think I look crazy so
I'm ready for them to like go back to
normal okay I guess they could go down a
little bit but you know I'm just loving
I'm like inject Amal I'm like Daenerys
burn em all so who was the other person
and then my best dress regardless of the
theme just like beautiful outfit was
Haley Baldwin Bieber oh man if they're
gonna say Hailee Steinfeld then I was
like oh man she looked oh my god no but
she was camp that was campy but she was
camp for matron she was camp for
Instagram like when that whole
collection came out and it was like me
yeah like she was like I'm wearing that
bomb right and like I just expected more
from her you know what's so funny is I
think part of the reason why the e-news
I don't even know what to call it like
it wasn't even a show because everyone
was little retired the side fringe
coverage was so boring it's because like
they have been so like since the days of
Joan they have taken so many steps
towards like being nice and like the
making fun of someone's outfit is now
considered bullying which is so crazy
like that's just not the case like you
aren't what you wear like it's so stupid
but they really every ever even the bad
people were - Wow or if they didn't like
it like I don't think anyone was really
crazy about the healthy staff but they
were just like talking about the context
behind the meme and the runway right it
was just like they would say anything
just not to say anything even slightly
like negative which is so stupid because
that's funny
no and it's also fashion like people
make mistakes and it's it's not that
serious
but yeah so you're like I'm in the
beginning of the their coverage they
weren't saying anything made about
anyone but no one had really showed up
looking crazy out and then towards the
end you know everyone comes in full
filled metal jacket and they didn't say
one cross thing about anyone so you're
telling me they loved every single look
is that what you're telling you no it's
so unrealistic and it's so stupid and
it's it's not like if you trust them w
WJ d like I want people who will put
their neck on the line and say across
thing about a celebrity who's not
dressed well because they're giving the
people the truth more celebrity yeah
thank you maybe the celebrity's not
gonna like them maybe a Justin Bieber
Tory and grant they are gonna tweet
about you but you gave us the truth and
we will never forget that what I
actually really liked was they
interviewed Jimmy Fallon really quickly
and he was like I literally don't
understand what's going on here I'm just
like no I'm gonna be quiet and they make
fun of everything tomorrow that's like
what a normal person should say
yeah comedian US comics so who was your
worst dress then you know I didn't think
anyone actually looked like ugly I
really like was just so disappointed in
the Hailee Steinfeld especially because
on this show we said I can't leave she's
been to nine Mecca calots and every
single time she turns it out in a look
she got a stylist out for her 21st
birthday and then she showed up like
just really not looking well but I
wouldn't necessarily say she's my worst
dress on theme she was on theme on this
person was on theme too but I just I'm
really sad to say I think Lilly
Reinhardt was my worst dressed that's a
really good one
Cole looked so like weird and good and
campy and like he looked hot still like
he kind of looks like F P like I was
just really feeling it and them together
like their outfits were not cohesive
like he was more like fun camp she was
more like serious marie-antoinette camp
and I just I know she doesn't have a lot
to say and what she wore cuz she was
just like excited to be there and the
designer just dresses you but I really
was not into it especially when she came
off of like the most epic moment last
year with H&M yeah that's a very good
one I want to say one thing in defense
of Hailee Steinfeld one thing we were
robbed of her look because when I'm
looking at it in pictures it's cute and
it's campy and she looks young and fun
but we saw her for the first time in the
corner of the E news coverage from like
a terrible angle and we were like oh my
god that's Hailee Steinfeld and it
ruined whatever was coming next
it ruined it for us yeah so like maybe
if I had seen a photo first
I could have appreciated that look more
also I just want to say that Judith
Leiber was the big winner of the night
every single person was carrying a
Judith Leiber handbag she is
unbelievably camp and like I'm obsessed
with her Instagram and I always comment
as if it's my best friend I'm like your
best Oh Judith lol and like Emily did
not oh does is in their new commission
so like and then that's my other friend
I'm like yeah Emily Ratajkowski oh my
god that butterfly had peace like that
was beautiful like just true beauty yes
I don't know I struggle with her because
it's like she looks like a beautiful
angel but like so much nudity
that's her you know and that's camp is
it I guess at the end of the night
you're always getting naked I can you
know if we're and then false if we're
talking about you like are you so crazy
like that's Kim okay I don't know it's
just like to me I don't know
in a way she always play like even
though that was a dairy a piece in a way
she always plays itself does she just
like relies on her body I'm naked how
could you how could you dislike it I
want to take your temperature on two
things one is the rivendell cast like
last year it was just silly Reinhart and
Cole Sprouse it was like a really big
deal that they were there and I think
they were there more because of like him
and her
but now Camila Mendez in melton went and
so did Madeline Patrick I thought was
really shocking which I thought was
really shocking and if kami Mendes and
just and Melton had gone I would've been
like oh okay finally like justice per
the fact that Madeline was there like
Anna Wintour stands riverdale cool for
her I hope you're enjoying the season
and I'm here for it there the next gen
agreed 100% and that is a move of her
being in tune and speaking of next gen
the second thing I wanted to ask you
about was James Charles so I had heard
rumor that you Charles and Emma Chiu
clear my throat James Charles and Emma
Chamberlin were supposed to be there
Emma Chamberlain liked in a partnership
with Louis Vuitton so I thought she was
gonna be there but she wasn't there just
James was he was everything's in her way
I should say I'm time after time like
really like uninspired by Alexander
Wang's like design when he brought Kylie
and she just wore like that with those
weird sunglasses in the black dress like
I'm just like so uninspired by him true
but he did Haley Baldwin's dress oh she
looked great and she looks great and I
want to say this song made the dress
agreed it made like otherwise she's just
a beautiful girl on a pink dress and
looking thin with her back arch in a way
that said that she definitely practiced
the reason why she was arching her back
like that so it was that so in one photo
you could see the front and the back
which was so important for the looks
otherwise if to post two photos every
time so the song that said weighing
saved it for me who did he dress that
you were just saying James Charles Oh I
mean she just were people were joking
lady looks like it's gonna Coachella
right and it was hardly a joke the issue
with the Met Gala and like with all this
coverage it's like you want to blame
like you're like oh how could Lily
Reinhart wear that but it's like she had
zero say in what support horse so like
the blame is really on the designers but
then it's the celebrities who take the
brunt of it and so many celebs like
really feel so uncomfortable what
they're wearing and that's a story that
I want to talk about was Kim's Instagram
story talking about all of her years at
the Met Gala and Kim is now in a place
where I feel like she can you know give
she collaborates yeah and there are a
few celebrities who are at that level
but if you're lucky enough to be invited
by [ __ ] like Stella McCartney you
just shut up and get fitted right so
blessing but also a curse so like
someone it was someone else's idea for
Lily right here to look like fu trinket
she looked just like epic also it really
was the Hunger Games Capital fashion yes
and I feel like [ __ ] but justice for
Elizabeth fixated and say choo-choo
totally there was a few people that were
missing and also like this is gonna be a
really controversial statement but not
really one of they were stressed like in
a such a disappointing way is Giselle
okay a great apparently she's never on
theme and she doesn't care about the
theme great so she can wear any dress in
the world and she was that like she does
know like it was a sustainable
eco-friendly like all the dress was made
from the tears of orphans that's cool
but then you're saying like it was a
fine dresser but like she could wear it
to a party she went to the beach she can
wear to the beach but like for the Met
Gala
you're not gonna care about the theming
you're just gonna wear whatever you know
more no jewelry and you're gizelle yeah
I agree step it up agreed also another
one of my best dress is Naomi Campbell
oh my god love they really looking
beautiful loved every minute agreed oh
great um and I got to see a great shot
of the feet because someone who works at
E is so weird
I must have hired an eider which was
snitches joke because is unemployed
right now and all the whole feet it's
like they got no good celebrities I'm an
interview they got no good celebrities
on the stream and then once they did
they were just showing their [ __ ]
feet totally what did you think about
Kim you know what I'm and I send this
before we watch any of the live stream
it's like I'm consistently just in terms
of the Met Gala like a little
underwhelmed by the Kardashians because
they really care more about like looking
pretty and having their glam snatch than
they do about like being in theme and
maybe looking like a little off what you
know I totally get like I don't know
like I much rather look pretty but so
Kim this time like went for the theme
and not only did I not really get it her
body looked like so weird
and I just I don't know I wasn't like a
living for it as much as I was living
for Kendall and Kylie and honestly like
Kris yeah I know I was living for
Kendall Kylie Kim the more pictures that
I see a bit more pictures that she post
it's like the way that she wants us to
see us some more I like it but my first
initial reaction was like what and also
it's like like a knee-length dress at
the Met Gala right yes she like never
can really get it for the Met Gala last
year if she did
she just went plain white off the
shoulder dress with like literally no
machi okay actually yeah she did get and
she was a heavenly body but the plain
white like that was mad and then the you
know yeah mrs. Doubtfire couch yeah okay
we'll get into it more and more but so
now it is time to eat with the fast five
stories that you need to know that
wasn't the story may come and take a
bite out of your womanhood snow wasn't
the story was just cities us in but we
have three Met Gala stories first Jamie
Foxx and Katie Holmes make it if Met
Gala official posing as a couple on the
first major event red carpet which is a
big deal I didn't even know that because
I was watching a news and obviously they
didn't show us anything important oh I'm
sorry while they didn't hit the cut red
carpet together the couple posed for
photos inside the event in front of the
flower wall and in the main met hall
looking cozy with their hands around one
another as they stopped for
photographers which they've never done
before they're always photographed at a
tables today next week yeah they're like
like with an iPhone she doesn't want to
poke the bear of Scientology maybe she's
out of her contract I feel like so bad
for like I think about her all the time
I know but I feel as though they've been
together for a really long time her and
Jamie Foxx may feel like they're really
happy I think so too because they don't
like seek like this slime like you know
yeah oh and I just want to say another
very disappointing person in outfit
JLo just like so thirsty like thirsty so
been there done that Rihanna and Khloe
Kardashian yeah and like she could have
warned that dress and even the headpiece
like an award show it look wasn't
special no it wasn't special it was like
the obvious thirsty choice and it was
like almost too safe but her safety like
it was actually a risk Oh chilly I need
to clear my throat so season huh nice
okay Katie Holmes and Jamie Foxx do you
ship I do I'm actually really happy for
them I feel like Jamie Foxx needs just
like a stable woman in his life she's a
mom she's a businesswoman like I think
they're both really good for each other
she needs like a little excitement in
her life I feel like she's been Kimmy
Schmidt the mole woman for years like
she just needs to leave the house and go
to parties and like he can offer her
that they both like fit each other's
needs really well yeah and I'm glad that
they have
countenance or whatever you know the
contract ending company they started to
step out a little while ago actually
like a good amount of time ago and then
like something happened with the
contract you know she got a cease and
desist or some [ __ ] and they really took
a step back and I thought they had
broken up but no no they're here at the
Met Gala I'm here for and you know what
then like being required to like keep it
keep it back like behind the curtain was
probably really good for their
relationship like when you're like just
being thirsty in the spotlight like that
can be good and thrust into the public
eye be kind of thirsty in the spotlight
Nick and Brianna really but tal Jonas
and Kevin Jonas as predicted were
unfortunately not invited which is just
like it's devastating it's devastating
Sophie and Joe were there did you see
what Nick tweeted yes that he should
have already is Camp Rock no he put a
side-by-side of him a little finger and
he's like protective al
oh I said with a little mustache like
little finger he also tweeted that he
should have just worked his camp rock
t-shirt that is so funny I wish he
should have worn it like under his
blazer that would have been so cool and
I just wouldn't give an honorable
mention to Elle Fanning who actually was
the only person who looked like a camper
Oh she'll chew on all the necklaces and
like the camp bracelets and her hair and
a high pony like she really took our
interpretation of camp I'm gonna
interrupt you to let everyone know that
it's net it is now 11:00 a.m. Eastern
Time 10:00 a.m. Central Time so
Minneapolis Austin Chicago Milwaukee New
Orleans patreon presale has now begun go
to the toast after dark or the patreon
page to get the code and the link that
is once again Minneapolis Austin Chicago
Milwaukee New Orleans that was just a
word from our sponsors oh yes Priyanka
Priyanka gotta go o Elle Fanning yes
yeah so she was a cutie she's all these
all these other looks are coming back to
me now I get a good fuse between
Elizabeth Olsen
because she's like a sister to the
younger sister but like is arguably like
more famous and beautiful I don't know
yeah usually the other sister is like
the wienie like that's so sad music but
like you know it's like younger sis on
oh the Ashlee Simpson yeah and it's like
the like you would up you know but like
when the younger sister just comes out
stuntin it's interesting and I get them
confused oh yeah also someone mentioned
my li what were your thoughts um okay so
really interesting I don't know if it
was the same designer but it was like
the same exact structure as like oh
she's dressed like it was just weird cuz
like I kind of think like oh she looked
better
I completely agree but I just loved it
like if someone's working in someone
square in green like right I just like I
kid will never take advantage of my lay
looking normal cuz you know never it
might be a fleeting thing so she just
had straight hair and you know she wore
pretty dress and I actually liked your
tights so you know what I Miley gets her
own scale you know for sure like on the
scale of Miley's it was a good luck for
Miley but I feel like she is someone who
would so embrace this theme memory she's
to do all those crafts and not even in
camp counselor way dead pets yeah let's
talk about no tongue kiss who's in the
Susan Sontag way I feel like she would
really embrace like all of those crafts
that she used to do when she used to
work with mosquito all the time like I
felt like she could have you know just
farted out a better dress ya know it was
just very laid-back for a theme that was
really made for her but like I said I
will never ever take advantage of Miley
or be ungrateful of Miley just looking
like a normal and pretty because that
was such a you know a distant thing for
me for me can I guess I mean the short
bangs were the risk
sure whatever I'm just I'm really happy
for nily normal eyes and also she also
looks happy highly highly loved highly
we know what she looks like file a fun
Miley totally um some of the Massino
looks were some of the best looks I just
went at Kasey Musgraves Tracee Ellis
Ross loved the picture frame um who was
the other one was cardi B no I don't
know I don't know Nicki Minaj like looks
a little stupid beyond yeah like oh she
was mosquitos Oh was a chandelier Katy
Perry mosquitos yes and also the
hamburger yes that was a little stupid
but him it was camp and I said before
the show even started that um she was
gonna really embrace the scene because
she is like cam and I'm not just just
you know I love she was there from you
to the bees right so I'm glad that she
you know lived up agreed
oh and Lady Gaga I'm sorry I guess she
walked through her before hours before I
Berwyn Oh nailed it perfection I love
that she had the early shoot so much we
know and some she had to get there early
for that we were watching the live
stream do a lip at her big ballgown was
like knocking out JLo and a rod like
even the most respected people couldn't
get a square inch on the carpet because
if you're invited that means your
procedures but
goggle was surely the first person there
there was not a single person on the
carpet that's why she had so much space
for all traffic changes I wonder what
she wore inside when she was on stage
she was in her naked outfit oh my god I
think that's what she wore she's looked
I mean if I looked like that I would
[ __ ] anywhere less than that but that is
camp by the end of the night you're just
naked
yeah just gonna dip it in the lake
totally so I loved I loved it it was
like there's no need to comment on it
cuz she now seems she was the theme and
she was the host so like everything like
that's it yeah done extras how and her
facial expressions we were just so cute
yeah okay next story shockingly Georgina
Chapman attends the 2019 Met Gala after
Harvey Weinstein scandal actually not so
shockingly because Vogue did a very
flattering piece on her a few months ago
so obviously Friends of that and they're
trying to bring her back into the fold
and she dressed Constance Wu who looked
incredible I mean that's always been the
big struggle of like his true Geena
Chapman like you know complies complicit
whatever at the end of the day Marquesa
makes up the most beautiful dresses and
I would put Constance Wu maybe not theme
wise but just like in my list of whoever
looked the most beautiful and who's ever
who's ever dress was like the most
objectively stunning so regardless of
how you feel I'm glad she was there
because the dresses that she make
deserve to be like this way each and
every day I agree yeah and like as
consumers we need Marchesa and they
learned that lesson the hard but when I
was looking for just so a nice dress
once and there was nothing out there
except for Marchesa and so I supported
her and I will continue to because I
support talent doesn't matter like you
know now going forward she's standing on
her own two feet she's making these
chances for people to stand in on their
own two feet
you know like regardless of how you feel
I think she deserved to be there and you
know what it's like she has been through
a shitstorm and back let her go to the
Met Gala okay yeah so big deal that she
was there now I want to talk about some
people who were there shockingly and who
weren't there because I did not see the
Rihanna me neither I didn't see I did
not see two are both previous hosts like
they're on the committee right they're
friends with Anna and it's surprising
because I feel like Rihanna no matter
where she's at in life she always goes
because like she loves a good theme and
everyone loves her and she's always
going to carnival looking like camp as
hell so this would have really been a
moment for her right and then Taylor
Swift like is in the press junket right
now like why
what she missed out on the biggest press
opportunity of Taylor Swift what did you
think of Karlie Kloss is like very
understated like Gucci dress I mean I
liked the dress in general and like I
love what Dapper Dan is doing for gucci
so like i don't want to hate on the
dress it was just like it didn't scream
at gallatin and it certainly didn't
scream camp and it certainly didn't
scream Karlie Kloss right and like gucci
is so cool and this is like might be
mean but like Harley cost has enough
going for her that I can say it Carley
class is not cool enough for Gucci yes
she she's the face of Michael Kors she's
a lot of things but she's not cool she's
very like she does Express she does
Michael Kors she's she's elegant you
know yeah she's refined she's not like
edgy Gucci like Gigi print everywhere
right that's true so it didn't work for
me I thought the dress was cute I think
she's cute but together was it no it's
gonna be a no for me I really missed
Taylor Swift I feel like in this new era
of hers like bright colors happy like
pretty vibes like she could have went
with something just like stunning and
like really a little like out of her
comfort zone also where was ariana yeah
well she's on tour I know but like it's
the first Monday in May you know like
get this is her year like she went last
year when it wasn't even her year like
this really was her year and she could
have she is camp like both senses really
yes because she wore the Sophie shorts
and she wore could wear like a big tulle
dress
avant-garde drag she's all of it
she's flamboyant like she would have
crushed it so I missed her presence who
else was there wasn't there that was
surprising I thought we talked about
this a little bit but not on the show
Maggie Rogers was there we had to see
her but I saw a picture on Twitter
I saw her stories and you know what I
was whelmed yeah maybe even underwhelmed
she went with coach along with Michael B
Jordan I love Michael Jordan totally
yeah I didn't like love look I mean it
was surprising that she was there
considering she really is like a new
artist yeah and I don't know I guess I'm
you know what I imagine Anna Wintour as
a fan of her music because she is kind
of like indie you know it was an
interesting choice especially because
the person I would compare her to Moses
Kacey Musgraves like this was Kacey
Musgraves first Mechelen like she just
won Album of the year in 400 gram he's
like she should have been about it now
like and she's so fashion like mega
Rodgers just wears like mom jeans right
and Maggie I was just put out her first
album like she's ready yet to like sit
can only go downhill from here for
Maggie Rogers right and like
we're clearly does not respect the hell
out of country music whatsoever because
there were so many other females in
country she kind of like she can't
invite ya upcoming publish Mary Morris
yeah he's really fashion totally um so
it's like I feel like she feels
compelled to him Mike Casey one because
Casey is so fashion yeah um but also
because she's like an undeniable force
in the initial music yet not even just
in country I just think like I mean I
just that's a great picture of Maggie
Rogers on the stream oh actually I
should it's great I just you know every
time there's like something that I don't
agree with I just blame out I went or
you know and I just I can't help but
just think of the moment where she's
sitting around the table like getting
approved guests like I wonder who was
invited by a designer and didn't get
approved that's what I want to meet you
that's what that documentary should have
been not that boring ask corporate gray
music thing that they made for the first
Monday in May boring stuff so I fell
asleep on the plane I couldn't I didn't
watch it I started it and I was like
nope not that bored okay so anything
next Mac else story before we get into
some other news pregnant Kim Kardashian
cried after her first Met Gala in 2013
Kim Kardashian may seem confident no
matter what she's wearing but she does
have some fashion regrets the beauty
mogul took to Twitter on the first
Monday and made a look back at her past
Met Gala looks before last night's event
Kardashian said she was so nervous to
attend the Anna Wintour hosted fat for
the first time as Kanye's plus one quote
I didn't know anyone and I'm sure no one
wanted me there lol she captured in
photos of herself at the event which she
attended while pregnant with her first
child North while it was rumored that
went or herself previously banned
Kardashian from attending the annual
party voc's editor-in-chief cold
shoulder paled in comparison to the
public reaction to the stars floral gown
with matching gloves and shoes her
Riccardo Tisci designs Yvonne Shayla
quickly became a meme and was compared
to a grandmother's couch on social media
Plus Kardashian revealed that she did
her own lipstick for the evening and she
admitted the color was so off quote I
went home and cried after I've
insecurities but this is one of my fav
looks now obviously and looking at it in
hindsight like she looks so beautiful
she and there's no perfect silhouette
for a pregnant woman
yeah she's like so pregnant like her
face is like be to the guys the lipstick
is fine like she looks it's really not
that bad yeah it's a wonderful pregnant
leg this is like such a sad story yeah I
like can't help but feel responsible cuz
I couldn't know I was posting memes
about Kim of course you know cuz then
it's like I feel both ways now now it's
like we need to be meaner
we need to everyone
we don't need to be meaner but like
everyone's to stop being so sensitive
but there's also like no these are
people with real feelings like we made
Kim Kardashian cry yeah
and she looks great and like and that's
what said I did not know that I don't
went or is such a little [ __ ] and
honestly like good on Kim from being
like you know the bigger person but like
the fact that at one point in time Kim
Kardashian was banned from the Met Ball
is so crazy and the only way she could
have gotten invited is that Kanye
demanded that she come yeah that's
[ __ ] I don't wait towards such a
loser like now every person that lower
is what she is every person on that
carpet he's wearing something that is
slightly inspired by something Kim has
worn like regardless if of whether you
want to admit it or not everyone's
wearing puffy jacket and beggars shorts
and Kim was wearing that two years ago I
was like what the hell's is between ya
and now she Kim's only wearing like
weird tight spandex things and I bet you
in a year that's whatever one's gonna be
wearing yeah we're even willing to is
pregnant she only wore like tight
dresses to the knee with the kimono
that's all that's what have 9 min
[ __ ] right now - ya know it's like
the fact that Kim is just like the
better person obviously cos Kim so once
I go to the mecca and be a part of the
fashion world but like I hope when I
don't went or like eventually like Lee's
her job but she should have done years
ago like Kim gives her good slap in the
ass no but she mom because she's just
like a class act
you know that makes me really mad yeah I
know that so then she talked about some
of the looks of other years which I
honestly didn't even remember she felt
better certain years she was pregnant
let's say when she wore this like full
sheer dress that was just like so Kim K
but they do remember the year where they
were beat bleached eyebrows and Kanye
was robbed of contacts she said she felt
horrible that year she hadn't lost her
baby weight and like she was back to
being insecure oh but she looks good
there and everyone likes it her outfit
yeah it helps when people like I know
you're not just care about what people
think but it helps whenever one thinks
you were good you know even if you don't
feel good but I think last year she felt
her best I mean she looked her best yes
she also she looked great this year and
I think for her it's all about her
weight like she's like I it's like if I
feel fat I'm I looked at him ruin your
day so I feel like she felt great last
year I feel like she feels great this
year like she's really been working out
he wishes don't face shooting her photos
I know but like so much as long as Emily
Ratajkowski is still face tuning like
Kim Kim
it's crazy yeah it's crazy that like
when you look at slap bases like the
models that they stream themselves like
the tiniest girls and it's like they're
into care too and it's like what are
they like make their belly button bigger
no hope for the rest of us no they make
their neck longer longer and then like
tighter it's so crazy
it's just crazy like what people who
really should have been insecure about
anything like what they're insecure
about you know yes I'm insecure about
the obvious things like huge bellies and
double chins but like what a big arm
what do people without arms chins and
bellies and what are they insecure what
keeps them up at night they're insecure
about their necks then I guess crazy
okay next story another Kim K News no
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West fourth
child has not arrived yet so so
yesterday yesterday there was a bunch of
fake news that that they kind of started
yeah that Kim and Kanye had had their
fourth child because Kim shared a
screenshot of text that West had said
her early Monday about her great life
and one red married with four kids was
married with four kids getting people
out of jail cover a Vogue cover a Vogue
he was just like listening like all the
things they're not being like you should
be so grateful it was a yeah it was and
then it was like dreams do come true it
was really sweet it was like for kids
question check it exact had to write
something like that to you what were the
things same I would be like mom to
co-write sold-out tour hopefully God
willing tickets available on Friday um
and you know big lips okay
what would you say this is so hard it's
like what do I value it's like your
whole life in four sentences oh my gosh
like I need a minute sorry
cuz it's like I'm not gonna like I don't
know I feel like for me it's like my the
things that make me up is this like
great handbag collection great okay no
not that like seen vibes uh-huh the
scenes have never been seen here never
the morning toast yeah like in the face
of all the add never been toastier the
memory one podcast in Massachusetts and
New Jersey um no really just very
positive a new apartment it's just what
might one of my greatest joys as it
should be um-hmm it's one of my greatest
joys okay we very full lives we identify
if it could always be fuller but it
could always be that's well you know
what I feel like people who are always
just looking for a mixed thing you have
to enjoy what you have right now so yeah
I could say you know what I could do
more I also do you like Bruce Jenner
right now give me a motivational speech
no totally but I feel like everyone and
they always
the greatest showman when they're like
you want it to be so much more than you
are and I feel like all the time I'm
reading stories about people who are
just like not happy with what they have
and then they go and seek more and then
it all crumbles
I definitely feel as if this is a
personal shot no oh my god you know what
it's like I'm not one of those people
who's like not happy with what I have I
just want more but I still appreciate
what I have you know it's a match I
wasn't referencing you at all but I feel
like or always much like American greed
and take your life yeah sign the for it
you know you have this have wanting to
be so much more than you are agreed so
but also you also should be ambitious
right that's like where do we draw the
line between being someone else and you
see an omission right we don't okay
they've been kind of story I guess is
how people and American weird story
spooky step multiple guests allegedly
drugged at Jake Paul's house party what
YouTube star Jake Paul threw a massive
rager at his LA mansion and the
authorities are now investigating
reports that party goers have their
drinks spiked the LA County Sheriff's
Department said at least one person
filed a complaint after the 22 year old
threw a bash at his Calabasas home
Saturday night for the rapper desiigner
quote we had a person who came forward
she indicated she was drugged at this
party on Saturday the drugging
allegation came as a concerned mom took
to a private Facebook group Sunday night
claiming her underage daughter and a
group of pals had something slipped in
their drinks my daughter was it was at a
party in Calabasas last night for
YouTube Jake Paul the Houseman was
mansion filled with young people she in
the moms of Conejo Valley Paige she
ended up in the hospital with eight
other girls who had been drugged and
ended up at West Hills Hospital
incoherent in the post the momma claims
the girls were half naked and unable to
walk or talk oh my god this is a
horrible story the sheriff's office said
they're aware of the Facebook posting
have reached out to the investigate
further we called hospitals so far we
have not received information from local
hospitals that young girls were drugged
that's really [ __ ] up holy [ __ ]
I mean here's I mean do I think Jake
Paul was running around putting the
drinks drugs and girls drinks no it's
just like automatically he's gonna be
associated because it's like Jake Paul
says he's with people who write it could
be just like someone who showed up at
his house like once a rupee a bunch of
girls like who just got invited to the
party but this is so crazy like I guess
I never realized I like dragons
one just cuz it happened so frequently
and like random bars and like you wake
up the next morning like you never get
justice like it's illegal yeah
you know the police should be look yeah
but like any time I've ever heard of
anyone getting roofied they didn't
realize till the next day and like they
you don't know who did it right there
you couldn't originate from the same
house party you know yeah so I never
like really realize like it's like a
crime it's a major crime I hope justice
is served and I I'm not Shady because it
only happened to girls right but it's
like when these eight girls were - if it
would happen to eat girls and they were
all together like with snapchat and
everything they might be able to trace
back like yeah where it happens together
that's true just a huge lesson you could
never it's an expensive thing but if you
put your drink down you got to get a new
one yeah always
yeah but it also could have been
something in the in the punch in the
punch
yeah then would have been more than
eight people and then also like first
rule of being like a party girl like
myself never drink the punch yeah yeah
yeah but it it would have happened to
the party right it wouldn't just been
like a group of girls unless it was just
like punch free for girls yeah don't
drink the punch for girls don't drink
the p4g okay that's all we have for you
today but decubitus man from Peru I
watched it this morning I knew thing I
told you was like watching in the
morning there's no productive it
motivates me to get out of bed because
I'm like if I don't get ready I won't
have enough time too much of 45 minutes
without commercials and the amnesia that
I have like I felt lost in it I truly
wouldn't remember but I remember okay
and it was good it was good it was juicy
I don't even know where to begin but you
know when I take away the first thing I
want to say is like Tom Sandoval shut
the [ __ ] up
no totally I was gonna say Tom and
Ariana are like really I mean I'm
enjoying that they're they're making an
interesting because they are really
teetering the line which we like James
and everyone else and if it was just
everyone against James like that would
be boring I'm so from a television like
consumer perspective I'm enjoying like
the the fights that their ambivalence is
creating but they're being so like
unreasonable and something weird is
happening where Lisa like wants to
publicly be like James you can't talk to
women that way but she is doing
everything she can to keep James a part
of this show Raquel is now away tryst
that gives them another season or two
right and I think it's the businesswoman
in her under
standing that James is good for the show
the show is good for her if James
Emmerich he'll go away it's a group of
people all getting along and that's not
interesting so she wants to keep them on
the show for her own personal gain
yeah and so like really the problem
everyone was having last night it's like
James you're saying horrible things but
then they were all being like a little
bit G like saying right Kelly you can't
call yourself a beauty queen but like I
don't know how many leg which is I have
to explain the shoe that's like saying
someone shouldn't call themselves a
beauty queen it's like nowhere near the
same as calling someone fat calling
someone a hillbilly calling someone
trash calling someone a [ __ ] like it's
just it's so stupid then you just topic
waiting everyone with James because he's
so not the same right also Warrick Hill
was saying like they're not making she
is a beauty queen she was missed to know
more when I was the way she taught
herself she was like I know you guys
think I'm just a beauty queen you think
I'm just this beauty queen who just
wants the limelight I'm like a lot of
gray and then they like that first of
all that's an attack on them saying
that's what they think of her and
they're like beauty queen we don't think
you're a beauty queen right like what do
you think is the Queen's right so it
wasn't totally out of nowhere um but it
was painful to get there and then at
certain point I just wanted to hear what
she had to say yeah no um it was just
stupid but I'm really here for Jack I
mean Britney just like defending her man
and her family totally and like [ __ ]
blow so like you ever back into a corner
like I want Britney their material in on
my side and then she was finally let's
shut the [ __ ] up Tom you're Jax his best
man I'm like being a friend right and
it's the if you have to shut up or not
say anything it's like when James was
making fun of Jax like taking a [ __ ] and
by the way there were so many jokes
about duty on the reunion it's like if
that's what your level of humor has
succumbed to later you're not funny
Tom Sandoval was like laughing so Tom
and Ariana were laughing so hard at
these bad jokes about his best friend
yeah it was it was really mean it was
really neat they like one is a CJ they
wanted to see James for the argument
whether or not they had to contribute or
not yeah agreed
Tom and Ariana were really bothering me
and you know what else was really
bothering me was the conversation about
Randall filming because when Patrick
wasn't filming I was like that's not
fair it's not but there's something
about
Lala's relationship and she was like my
relationship is different and I can't
explain it like I would not be impressed
with like them P jiaying around the
world like her being this like new
Beverly Hills if he was like slumming it
on a Bravo show like
part of the allure of her relationship
was like we don't know Randall and I
like that
also she she said what she was trying to
say so poorly she insulted everyone else
in what she said but I think the
difference is is that he is an older man
with a career he has more to lose by
being on a show whereas this show as
much as they have what to lose from it
they have everything to gain that's like
all the guys that Sheena brings on like
have everything to gain an instrument
and then someone like beau who like has
he has he is just what to gain also
because he's only there as Sassy's
boyfriend he he's not thinking like yeah
but Randall stepping onto the show
automatically opens up his life he has
ex-wives he has children and it's just a
can of worms that it's not even cuz he's
more successful it's just cuz he's older
and he has children and I also know it's
just a that's a TV watcher like I love
the mystery of like she's like am i
dating a football player and then it's
this guy and he's married he's not
married or is he separated and it's just
it's more interesting I don't need to
see how they live like that's like it
ruins the the mystery it's like gross
you will see their apartment you know
yeah and even Lama going on this show
and talking about Randall has opened
them up to so much criticism 50 cent if
if she wasn't able to talk about Randall
on the show he would have never got that
clip that he used against them so
without him even being there they're
subjecting themselves to so much
criticism I think she took a major step
this season and I was kind of bummed
that people didn't like how appreciate
appreciative a they they're down for all
the positives of Lala dating this rich
man they're going to Paris on the PJ and
they're enjoying the house in Bimini but
know when they when when it comes time
to like defend that there yeah but like
if Randall took one step onto the show
like he would be annihilated like it
could be really bad for his career
whereas like because there is so much
contention in their relationship like
they started off and like in you know
improper way that is technically
scenario who comes on me just love him
and we want to love him and no one's
look I didn't even know he was in
commercial casting like no one's looking
into him there to support Stassi where
it's like it would become about Randall
because he is so interesting you know it
actually maybe I would like Randall
being on the show because it would
become about something other than sir
right watching them meet in Paris right
now shopping at gucci tom ford how do
you afford that on a waste your salary
that's what we're supposed to believe
right also i want to watch that lisa man
like keeping Lala's [ __ ] for not having
grandma on the show it's like she should
be the last person to want him on the
show because like he will eclipse her
yeah completely
you know cuz they're like it used to be
she if they went on a trip and she got
them an upgraded room was like thank you
Lisa oh you know thing they go on a trip
and he gets him an upgraded plane and
it's like Thank You Randall now that
I'll just find like two million dollar
homes with stainless steel appliances
like getting ready to make their
hellofresh
boxes of course like they's hella fresh
and so do we
there's no so excite about hella fresh
because you have a new kitchen a new
kitchen I have all of my new appliances
and I'm about to hello fresh the [ __ ]
out of this hello fresh cooked meals
made simple hello fresh makes conquering
the kitchen a reality with deliciously
simple recipes hello fresh does all the
meal planning shopping and prepping so
you can focus on a healthier you and
happier family gets seasonal simple
recipes and pre measured ingredients
delivered right to your door every week
all meals come together in 30 minutes
max call for less than two pots and pans
and require minimal cleanup that's where
they really got me what's the cleanup
I'm not one Bend goes in the kitchen to
make like a souffle and he comes out
with like 75 pounds it's really [ __ ]
annoying
um so he eighty dollars II cook for 80
dollars off your first month of hello
fresh go to hello fresh calm slash toast
80 and enter the code totes to eighty
thats hello fresh calm slash toast
eighty and enter the code toast eighty
I'm so excited for my next hello fresh
delivery because I'm making enchiladas
oh you are yeah like I just had any
morning I'm making waffles am I gonna
have red beans for dinner if you don't
know that movie quote what chicken
nobody does there's like movie cuts and
he's like you're fat you're fat cuz I
need you like everyone knows but people
don't know it so I'm gonna be head over
heels with Freddie Prinze jr. and that
random girl who like never got famous
I'm where she lives in a model apartment
she pretends to be model but she fall so
I was pretty nervous really like works
at the Museum with all the old ladies in
the basement and then just go watch it
it's such a great movie it's such a
great just like early 2008 it's probably
go really hard movie to find I don't
know I watched it recently on nephilim
Netflix something digital and normal uh
red beans for dinner ok back to data
from Bros because I'm not gonna
I also wanted to talk about Lila jewel
in hand Oh during the reunion
she's just a queen she's looked
incredible and I feel like all the time
on Instagram she'll like do something
and everyone's like Lola looks crazy and
then every time she gets on TV she looks
so good so and it's so hard to look good
on TV it's easy to better alone right
it's better it's she looks better on TV
than she does I mean your phone in
pictures all this stuff so I don't know
it's just like whatever she's doing it's
really it's really working for me yeah
but what's not really working for me is
the current form out of the show but I
really feel like they need to evolve
next season and it looks like they're
not coming to they're still trying to
make that happen at Sur with Raquel and
it's really [ __ ] stupid and I would
absolutely love to just like have a show
they can still call benefit pearls that
has nothing to do with star they're all
now like moving into new stages in their
lives they all have new homes they're
all rich like show me spending money I
want to see what they bought in Shane
[ __ ] Paris at Gucci each and every
one of them has got bought a house now
yes she knew but a house in Palm Springs
Kristen bought a house in Beverly Hills
at Tom and Ariana bought a house in LA I
bought a house it's like come on Stassi
is a [ __ ] New York Times best seller
Tom and Katie bought a house they did
yeah it's it's enough it's enough they
must have really gotten paid the season
that's why every word last season that's
like they're all bought a house the same
time yeah and they bought houses they
didn't just move and that's also why
they've been living like in squalor for
so long one for the show and two because
they've been saving rent money and like
they bought million-dollar houses yeah
I'm so excited in here for it you see
John Blizzard being a [ __ ] thirst
monster on Twitter of course oh my god I
guess like magazine did some interview
with Ariana and they like just about the
conversation she had on the season
finale where she confronted Lisa and
they definitely took it out of
proportion mean like Ariana's mad at
least some whatever it was like a fake
tabloid [ __ ] jeonse SR John Blizzard
one of them put it on his Twitter and
was like Ariana how dare you but to all
the opportunities this advant prep is
giving you just about a two million
dollar house you think you could have
done that without Lisa and Ariana's like
dude we're friends like the fact you're
doing this on Twitter I was like who's
asking you right oh wow I mean I firmly
believe that the John's are behind
Papa gate I heard a rumor though that it
was Teddy that it was Teddy who sold the
story and that it's gonna come to light
this week if it was Teddy that told that
story makes no she goes I would have to
reevaluate everything my life like where
I put my couch like everything would
change because like that makes no
since yeah you have to switch seats
because like this clearly makes no sense
if you thought it made sense it makes no
sense no it's it's not possible
apparently read online it's coming out
with an article that's gonna really
clear the air about Teddy who being the
one who really really said article I'm
so super in Canton chant also I just
wanted to talk about the Lisa Vanderpump
Tom Tom thing because it was everything
we've been saying it was everything they
be saying except the one thing I didn't
agree with them on and I'm glad that
they're finally talking about the fact
that she treats them like [ __ ] but the
fact that they like demanded a salary
like that's not how works when you
invest in something you yield results
when the restaurant yields results and
they've been open for less than a year
and restaurants take a lot of time to
turn a profit I didn't agree with that
at all but on the respect thing
I really I understood and when Andy was
like how are you feeling overall with
this partnership I thought they were
gonna be like I mean regardless of all
the [ __ ] like we're excited to be
bar owners they were just like it's not
what we expected which is so weird
because like when you just look this
reunion was filmed like a month ago but
when you look at like pictures from Tom
Hummer like they're mean every day
you're there every night like Miley
Sarah Selena Gomez is their Lady Gaga's
their Dakota Fanning was just in Tom's
sidecar and so you think they're like
living life of Riley and like everything
just turned out like how they hoped it
women it's like no there's all this
drama going on which is so crazy and I'm
like why can't the show be about that
yeah I was thinking about it like more
and the thing is like Lisa Vanderpump
it's like at the end of the day she gave
them a bar in West Hollywood with their
name on it or they had to do was pay
fifty thousand dollars and yes they
contribute a lot and they've given her a
lot by allowing her to put their names
on it but and let's be real the
restaurant would be nothing if there
wasn't the Thom Association right it
would just be a Villa Blanca and nobody
goes to Villa it wouldn't be nothing cuz
it would be another pump and pump is
good but TomTom is but you know lady got
Miley Cyrus isn't going to a pump right
so Tom Thomas has made it another level
but if they started to do a bar on their
own with just their clouds they wouldn't
have been able to do that either so it
really is
they she's given them so much as much as
they've given her but they also give her
a [ __ ] ton of respect and so it's like
she doesn't owe them anything but to be
a decent human and treat them and a good
boss she's like not even equals partners
yeah it takes nothing no she was being
so unreasonable but she is loves
yeah agreed and the reunion was so real
and I wish the season was half as real
you know it's like finally we're taking
down the curtain and we're talking about
the things that we've been saying here
where it's like the season was so fake
and like such an orchestrated [ __ ]
with like James and whatever it's like
no this is the stuff I want to say yeah
where was this all season no but I'm
worried like Raquel working at Sur and
Lisa telling her she got the job on the
reunion like does not bode well for Nick
see no not at all it's like they're
still trying to make that happen right
there is a way to make it better come
parole still where they don't work at
Sur like maybe they've all started some
sort of business like where they work
like on the liquor brands on the tomtom
like in a more about like a way that is
realistic where they're making the money
that they're making yeah you know I read
Kristen and Carter aren't together yes
but we knew that because from watchstrap
inside when she went out a little bit
before this reunion she was just like
honestly I don't talk about it yeah but
like now they wouldn't say anything the
whole ruining Katie yeah she's so over
man she's so over he's not her house and
she wants to go home no and like she
just like would laugh or they tell James
to shut up like I think it's like so
frustrating for her like because
sometimes when you watch the show like
you do take other people sighs other
than hers because like they're making a
better point or like they're just saying
it in a better way but like I think that
if we were in this situation like I
think the way that she sees things it's
like a normal person it's like she sykes
up she gets like [ __ ] dragged on
Twitter for being a bully like it's so
new and so why would she speak up it's
like right no when she had a bad season
I went up to her wedding where she was
just like not in a good place and she
like cemented herself as the bully and
she can't get rid of that stench so now
anytime she speaks up people like you're
just buying Jeb yeah I think she had a
bad season this season she says she's
just had the ring in like there's no
point than me speaking up James is gonna
be here like I don't want to contribute
to his airtime good right exactly
she wouldn't she started talking to her
have forgotten choose her yeah okay well
Beverly Hills is on tonight so I'm gonna
rewatch I didn't watch last week oh my
gosh New York like last week's episode
and that I'm halfway through this past
week um
damn it's a rough season extremely
Barbara is not carrying her weight oh my
god I meant not at all I guess the most
interesting thing going on is Tinsley
and Scot which is so crazy
well because it's literally the most
boring thing I couldn't just like
need to take him to my shoulders and
shake her we need to become her there's
just like she needs to stop living in
the past
she is Sonia she is what they accused
Sonia of of like living in her past
memories and trying to be that girl
again Sonia it's just like I love her so
much and I love
she's so present but then she goes back
to the past because it's [ __ ]
interesting didn't she let a very
glamorous life whether I live there
right and like that's a part of who she
is
okay so here's it's happening is that
it's 10:30 in central time at 10 o'clock
all the Central Time shows went on sale
we're having a little problem Asbury
Park and the VIPs in New Orleans I know
I'm handling it just like hang on
and then in 30 minutes actually 28
minutes the [ __ ] beginning okay so I
just need everyone just like relax okay
your family friends together order like
7500 tickets it's only presale so just
like rocks that we've got if you're a
patreon member you got the code if
you're not there is still time
I haven't feeling some of the VIPs will
be sold out by the time that public sale
goes on so I suggest everyone just
become a patreon member and we're doing
it right episode this week about the
more the Met Gala recap so that yeah
patreon.com/scishow morning toast 27
minutes you guys 27 minutes 26 minutes
and 55 seconds until the beacon goes on
sale I just like need everyone joining
them to show up just like buy the ticket
please okay um thank you so much that's
all I have to say bye guys
you